[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz tolles grill
rezept ich werde süßkartoffeln grillen
mit einem grillunfall käse und dazu im
richtig leckeren salat das ganze könnt
ihr super vorbereiten und es schmeckt
wirklich wunderbar vor allem weil es
einfach mal was anderes ist vegetarisch
aber das verrate morattis an dieser
stelle als war noch nicht ich nehme hier
die zwei süßkartoffeln den gasgrill und
pfannen käse in chili geschmack etwas
sonnenblumenöl und später bereit sich
aus diesen zutaten einen salat so ich
habe jetzt hier tomaten avocados gurken
etwas petersilie koriander wird auch
passen
eine rote zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe und
chilis jetzt bereite ich zuerst mal die
süßkartoffeln vor
die habe ich jetzt bereits gewaschen und
die schneide ich jetzt einfach in china
diesen immer ziemlich hart also wirklich
aufpassen und das schreiben dürfen so
1,5 bis zwei zentimeter dick sein und
auf dem grill brauchen es kartoffeln
schon ziemlich lange vor allem wenn ihr
sie ihren ganzen grill
aber ich bin da wirklich nur diesen
grillgeschmack und wetzt vorher einfach
dümmsten als auch offen so ein bisschen
dämpfen damit der geschmack erhalten
bleibt denn wenn man sie in wasser kocht
dann wird man zum eigentlich stärker aus
und der geschmack verliert sich eben
auch also wenn ich sie dämpfen und dann
später nur kurz auf dem gremium
leg ich jetzt als reine dämpfe schale
und wenn ihr keinen dampfgarer habt dann
könnt ihr auch einfach die süßkartoffeln
im topf dämpfen das heißt einfach in
einen topf wasser geben aufkochen lassen
und zum beispiel einem fall zieht oder
in so einem dampfbad einsatz da dämpfen
also das geht auch und dann einfach so
lange bis sie fast ganz weich sind also
bis sie fast gar sind aber ein bisserl
bis dürfen sie schon noch haben
der rest wird nämlich dann auf dem grill
erledigt so die außen stück hatte kommt
nun auch noch drauf und jetzt einfach
bei 100 grad in dem dampfgarer hier
unten ist dann immer noch ein blech drin
für die flüssigkeit zum auffangen so
verschmutzt man den ofen noch nicht
die süßkartoffeln sind jetzt fertig
gedämpft jetzt kann ich den salat
vorbereiten darf er mich jetzt hier
tomaten und das andere gemüse war sich
ja schon gezeigt habe und ihr könnt aber
auch gerne einen salat eurer wahl machen
ich mache das jetzt hier sowieso eine
art salzer deswegen werde ich jetzt
alles was hier steht ganz fein würfeln
[Musik]
die avocado wird einfach halbiert den
kern nämlich raus und dann einfach hier
das fleisch herausnehmen
mit einem löffel und auch fein würfeln
manche gucken muss man schälen wenn die
haut und die schale so fest ist aber
dass jetzt die schale dran
das mag beides karten gucken immer am
liebsten
[Musik]
ich gebe dir noch ein bisschen gehackte
petersilie dazu koriander passt auch gut
aber korean da finde ich muss man immer
ganz vorsichtig dosieren ich mag zum
beispiel gar kein koriander einen hauch
von koriander würde schon gut reinpassen
aber das dürfte dann selbst entscheiden
die chilischote nehme ich jetzt noch da
nehme ich jetzt erstmal nur eine die
anderen werde ich dann hacken und dann
kann jeder noch mal den salat nachwürzen
und nachschärfen aber chili mag nicht
jeder weiß ist immer ganz hübsch aus
dann noch die knoblauchzehe die
grillplatte habe ich jetzt schon mal
erwärmt für die süßkartoffeln jetzt wird
ja gerade alles fertig und je nach
schärfegrad der chili bietet sich so wie
am handschuhe anzuziehen denn ihr müsst
wirklich vorsichtig sein chili anfassen
und dann zum beispiel ins gesicht kommt
tut wirklich ziemlich weh daher muss ich
vorsichtig sein
vorbereitet habe ich jetzt gleich werde
ich einfach noch mit salz pfeffer
olivenöl und zitronensaft würzen und die
salsa dann erst anrichten wenn es
wirklich auch ans essen geht jetzt gehe
ich schon mal hier rüber zur grillplatte
diese zwar da kommt jetzt ein bisschen
öl drauf so kann ich jetzt diese gattung
zu schreiben direkt aufträge für den
richtigen geschmack des kinos
die grill und tonnen käse und zwar die
server chili passt auch sehr gut zu
meiner dankbar den legen sie zu dem
ganzen drauf ihr könnt jetzt dieses
gericht auch ganz normal draußen auf dem
grill zubereiten
wir haben doch handelt daher machen sie
jetzt hier auf dem grillplatz
es muss einfach von beiden seiten schön
kross anbraten
[Musik]
sie ist auch wenn diese sich manche
sagen ich will eigentlich sagen dass es
dir mal die sprache verschlägt ja ich
wollte gerade sagen ich weiß ich nicht
sagen sollte ich mag skater und einen
free tiert muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich
sagen das ist ja als pommes frittiert
was hat man gibt sind ja man kann doch
mal ehrlich sein was man ganz cool sagen
also high school liebe ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen chili war in der salat mit
avocado sowie es so wie es aussieht wenn
auch cool aber ich glaube auch also ich
sage das jetzt her
du sagst ich deine ehrliche meinung ich
sagte meine ehrliche meinung und ich
muss sagen das ist doch mal ne
frittierte okay also ich habe mir
gedacht ich serviere dass er fürs auge
schön finde
ok muss man schon schön aussieht dann
schmeckt dem rad vielleicht gleich
bewertet lasse mich gerne überraschen
aber ich stelle erinnert die eckigen
käse stückchen und dann so vorurteile
beides ich halt auch so ein ding
vielleicht passt es ist gar caseys kann
was ich kann
das suchen
krimis das will das ist noch eine
steigerung von süßkartoffeln und kürbis
weil der schmeckt nämlich gar nicht alle
menschen formen also das machen wir die
salsa die schutzmittel grün
ihr könnt natürlich auch den rotanteil
erhöhen indem ihr mehr rot reimer
tomaten das irgendwie schön die farbe
ist perfekt auch schon besser ich es
erstmal ist ruh ich mir sicher bin dass
mir schmecken wird die variante ich
glaube halt dass das gut passt weil das
so fruchtig
das ist also keine chance ich hab nur
eine chili man merkt schon wo man kann
da auch noch die koreaner bahrain machen
also dann vegetarisch gilt dieser diese
salat für käse genial
jetzt mache ich mit dem fleisch pasta
gut
komme ich allein ist er stimme nicht
das ist gar nicht so einfach
ich habe es probiert aber dann machen
wir einfach so die these mit rico
schmitt ich glaube es ist jeden menschen
so geht wirklich ich glaube ich
frittiert richtig lecker diskutiert bei
hans im glück zum beispiel ist es immer
geld ich weiß warum dort den ich mal die
süßkartoffel einfach das wissen genauso
aber frittiert vega lag
und wir haben selbst definiert das
rezept macht es gerne mal nach verlinkt
uns auf eure fotos und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]